bonsoir ce merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france pourquoi demander
cette heure enquête aujourd'hui bas
parce que il n'y a pas de vaccin contre
le plan et tout incorporation de plomb
est dangereuse pour les organismes
humains et animaux aussi et donc à
partir du moment où il ya eu des
quantités énormes de plomb dans répandue
de pousser à deux plombes répandu dans
la voirie parisienne autour de notre
dame et dans les arrondissements à
l'ouest de paris qui ont été survolés
par le par le panache nous estimons
qu'il ya des risques sanitaires
importants et c'est pourquoi nous nous
sommes constitués partie civile
notre première plainte simple a été
déposée le fin juillet 2019 on a reçu un
courrier du parquet ne disons que elle
serait est classée sans suite
le 20 décembre 2020 et donc nous ne nous
résignons pas à ce classement sans suite
nous voulons connaître toute la vérité
sur les risques sanitaires
environnementaux les dommages sanitaires
et les dommages environnementaux que
cette catastrophe qui peut être simulé
une catastrophe industrielle a connu à
vous écouter à vous entendre on se
demande pourquoi il n'y a pas eu une
enquête avant et que dans une certaine
mesure il n'est pas obligatoire bah il
ya eu une enquête
il y à une enquête ouverte sur les
causes de l'incendié pour essayer de
répartir les responsabilités entre les
différentes parties prenantes négligente
qui n'ont pas renforcé le système d'
alerte samedi alors que notre dame était
en cours de de restauration est par
contre le parquet du tribunal judiciaire
de paris estime qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'ouvrir dans un premier
temps qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
d'ouvrir une enquête sur les risques
sanitaires
c'est pourquoi est ce que votre
association avait déjà déposé plainte
pour les mêmes motifs c'était en août
2010 mais classée sans suite
peut-on davantage y croire cette fois ci
normalement le lepad la doyenne il date
de nous le doyen des juges d'instruction
qui sont saisi par une association de
protection de l'environnement à gré sur
l'ensemble du territoire
normalement il devrait être désigné un
juge d'instruction qui devra mener une
enquête non plus sur les causes de
l'accident et sur les conséquences de
l'accident mais nous pensons que toutes
les conséquences ont été minorés
parce que toutes les parties prenantes
qui ont participé par leur négligence à
l' incendie de notre dame sont
exactement les mêmes qui participent à
la reconstruction de notre dame
clairement aujourd'hui vous ressentez
une forme de laxisme ou de déni non
peut-être d'une certaine incapacité de
la magistrature au général à bien
comprendre les enjeux environnementaux
parce que là c'est une autre dame c'est
une cause majeure mais dans bien
d'autres tribunaux sur des sujets moins
graves ou presque quotidiens comme les
décharges de déchets par exemple la
justice française a une fâcheuse
tendance à classer sans suite
est-ce que vous avez rencontré des
riverains ou des personnes pardonnez moi
qui ont travaillé sur le chantier qui
aurait pu rencontrer des problèmes de
santé
oui on en a on en a rencontré mais ça a
tellement été un yo-yo dans les
décisions des parties prenantes la
préfecture de police la mairie de paris
le diocèse le ministère de la culture
la préfecture d'ile-de-france que les
informations étaient difficilement
accessibles et que surtout je prendrai
un seul exemple pour les enfants les
écoles ont été décontaminées à partir de
l'été 1 août septembre en six écoles la
rentrée a été retardé et il aurait fallu
les fermer tout de suite les
décontaminer tout de suite c'est ces
écoles et autres autres autre problème
il ya cinquante cinq mille enfants et
adolescents et nourrissent dans les
crèches les écoles les lycées ou à paris
à paris intra muros et il aurait fallu
faire un dépistage de plombémie sur ces
50 cent mille enfants quelque chose d'un
protocole relevant d'un protocole
systématique et non pas recommandé aux
parents cinq mois après l'instant de
faire des dépistages dans le cadre d'une
démarche volontaire merci beaucoup jacky
bonnemains ce directeur de l'association
robin des bois d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france